nuestro objetivo es encontrar el ph de
diferentes soluciones salinas empecemos
con esta solución acuosa de acetato de
sodio en donde tenemos iones de sodio n
a más y aniones acetato de h3c o menos
ahora los cationes de sodio no
reaccionarán con el agua pero los anolis
acetato sí y entonces el aniones de tato
es la base conjugada del ácido acético y
reaccionará con el agua funcionará como
una base tomará un protón y si agregamos
un h más al c h3c o menos obtenemos de
h3c o h y como le quitamos un protón al
agua entonces nos queda o h - el ión
hidróxido entonces escribamos las
concentraciones iniciales
nuestro objetivo es calcular el t
de una solución que inicia con una
concentración 0.25 molar de acetato de
sodio que es la misma concentración de
la unión acetato así que la
concentración inicial es de 0.25 molar y
suponiendo que nada ha reaccionado la
concentración de los productos es cero
ahora vamos con el cambio cuando el ch 3
c
o menos reacciona se convierte en c h3c
o h ácido acético así que la
concentración que perdemos de iones
acetato la ganamos en el ácido acético
supongamos que esta concentración que
reacciona es x entonces aquí perdemos x
pero ganamos x por acá y lo mismo ocurre
con el hidróxido ganamos una
concentración ahora analicemos cuando la
reacción alcanza el equilibrio la
concentración de acetato es de 0.25
menos x la concentración de ácido
acético es
y la concentración de hidróxido también
es x entonces escribamos la expresión de
equilibrio como el acetato funciona como
una base nos interesa que se capte es
igual a la concentración de los
productos entre la concentración de los
reactivos entonces es igual a la
concentración de ese h3c
h por la concentración de hidróxido o h
- entre la concentración de los
reactivos sin tomar en cuenta el agua
así que sólo tenemos la concentración de
acetato
ok ahora la concentración de ácido
acético al equilibrio es x
y la concentración de hidróxido también
es equis pero la concentración de
acetato al equilibrio es de 0.25 menos x
y ahí está y necesitamos el valor de
café para esta reacción que no lo
encontraremos en las tablas pero si
podemos encontrar el caa para el ácido
acético el ácido acético y el acetato
son un par conjugado ácido base y el
valor teca
para el ácido acético es muy fácil de
encontrar en los libros el ica
es igual a 1.8 por 10 a la menos 5 y
nosotros necesitamos el cap de entonces
cuál es el café de la base conjugado
bueno sabemos que para un par conjugado
ácido base que a por café es igual a cab
w la constante de ionización del agua
así que solamente sustituimos 1.8 por 10
a la menos 5 k
es igual a 1.0 por 10 a la menos 14
usemos la calculadora 1.0 por 10 a la
menos 14 entre 1.8 por 10 a la menos 5
es igual a 5.6 por 10 a la menos 10
entonces café es igual a 5.6 por 10 a la
menos 10 y esto es igual a equis
cuadrada entre 0.25 menos x ahora para
que sea más fácil supongamos que x es
mucho menor a 0.25 podemos decir que es
muy cercano a cero así que 0.25 menos x
es prácticamente 0.25
entonces nos queda 5.6 por 10 a la menos
es igual a equis cuadrada entre 0.25
calculemos el valor de x tenemos 5.6 por
10 a la menos 10 x 0.25
esto nos da 1.4 por 10 a la menos 10 y
si sacamos la raíz cuadrada nos queda
que x es igual a 1.2 por 10 a la menos
cinco entonces x es igual a 1.2 por 10 a
la menos 5 muy bien y que representa
esta x bueno con todos estos cálculos
necesitamos recordar x es la
concentración molar de iones hidróxido
entonces x es la concentración de iones
hidróxido y ya que conocemos esto
podemos calcular el ph
qué es lo que nos pide el problema
entonces primero necesitamos calcular el
p
h que es igual a menos el logaritmo de
la concentración de iones hidróxido es
decir menos logaritmo de 1.2 por 10 a la
menos 5 el pp o h es igual a menos
logaritmo de 1.2 por 10 a la menos 5 y
esto es igual a 4.92 entonces el pp o h
es igual a 4.92 y finalmente para
calcular el ph sabemos que te h más de
lo que es igual a 14 entonces si
sustituimos el p
h y le restamos 14 nos queda que el t h
es igual a 14 menos 4.92
esto es igual a 9.08 el ph es igual a
9.08 esta es una solución salina básica
hagamos otro problema
nuestro objetivo es calcular el ph de
una solución
0.0 50 molar de cloruro de amonio así
que tenemos
nh 4 más y cl menos los iones cloruro no
reaccionarán con el agua pero los de
amonio si entonces
escribamos nuestra reacción nh4 más
funcionará como un ácido donará un
protón al h2o y si el h2o acepta un
protón entonces se transformará en el
johnnie drone yo h 3 o más
el nh 4 + pierde un protón nos queda
nh 3 muy bien empecemos con las
concentraciones iniciales queremos saber
el ph de una solución
0.0 50 molar de cloruro de amonio que es
la misma concentración que tenemos de
iones amonio así que tenemos
0.0 50 molar y como todavía no ocurre la
reacción la concentración de nuestros
productos es 0 ahora vamos con el cambio
como nh 4 más se transforma en nh 3 lo
que perdemos de nh 4 más lo ganamos de
nh 3 entonces si perdemos una cierta
concentración x de amonio ganamos esa
misma concentración de nh 3 y por lo
tanto también ganamos iones hidronew
y finalmente cuando la reacción alcanza
el equilibrio la concentración de amonio
es de 0.0 50 menos x la concentración de
iones sidronio es x y de amoniaco
también es x ahora como el amonio actúa
como un ácido escribamos la expresión de
equilibrio acá y acá
es igual a la concentración de los
productos entre la concentración de los
reactivos entonces tenemos la
concentración de h3 o más por la
concentración de nh 3
la concentración de nh 4 más ya que no
tomamos en cuenta el agua
nh 4 más ahora la concentración de iones
hidronew al equilibrio es x entonces
escribimos x
y lo mismo tenemos para la concentración
de nh 3x entre la concentración de
amonio que es de 0.0 50 menos equis
entonces 0.0 50 menos x
y necesitamos saber el valor de acá a
que no es tan fácil encontrarlo para
esta reacción pero como estamos hablando
de un par conjugado ha sido base nh4 más
y nh3 el café de nh 3 si lo podemos
encontrar y este 1.8 por 10 a la menos 5
entonces para un par conjugado ha sido
base k
por cate es igual acá w donde k
es lo que buscamos cate es igual a 1.8
por 10 a la menos 5 y catch w es igual a
1.0 por 10 a la menos 14 usemos la
calculadora 1.0 por 10 a la menos 14
1.8 por 10 a la menos 5 esto es igual a
5.6 por 10 a la menos 10 entonces
nuestro k
es igual a 5.6 por 10 a la menos 10 y
esto es igual a equis cuadrada entre
vamos a suponer que x es mucho menor a
0.0 50 entonces si x es un número muy
pequeño podemos decir qué 0.0 50 menos x
es prácticamente igual a 0.0 50 entonces
entre 0.0 50 y ahora vamos a calcular el
valor de x tenemos 5.6 por 10 a la menos
0.0 50 y a esto le sacamos la raíz
cuadrada x es igual a 5.3 por 10 a la
menos 6 entonces x es igual a 5.3 por 10
a la menos 6 y x representa la
concentración de iones y drone ya
entonces una vez que calculamos la
concentración de iones hidronew para
saber cuál es el ph sabemos que el de h
es igual a menos el logaritmo de la
concentración de iones hidronew es decir
5.3 por 10 a la menos 6 vamos a calcular
lo menos logaritmo de 5.3 por 10 a la
menos 6 esto es igual a si lo
redondeamos 5.28 entonces nuestro p h es
igual a 5.28
así que tenemos una solución ácida que
era de esperarse por las sales que nos
dieron para este problema